aquí tenemos el motor del robot ahora
vamos a mirar dentro del motor para
conocer cómo funciona y de qué está
hecho vamos a estudiar el exterior
primero tenemos esta pieza hecha de
acero es una lámina de acero bañado en
zinc para protegerlo de corrosión
también tiene una cubierta de plástico
de este lado tiene aquí dos contactos de
cobre la corriente entra por uno de los
contactos y sale por el otro contacto
depende claro de la dirección en la que
fluya la corriente eléctrica y también
tiene un eje está hecho de acero cromado
ahora aquí tenemos un cojinete de bronce
que le permite al motor girar a una
buena velocidad quitarle la cubierta de
plástico para ver cómo es el motor por
dentro entonces puedes ver que unos
clips sostienen la cubierta los dobló
hacia afuera
quito la cubierta y vemos cómo es por
dentro estas dos pestañas se conectan a
estos dos pedazos de metal llamados
escobillas son de cobre y su función es
raspar esta pieza y así conducir
electricidad esta pieza es llamada
conmutador el conmutador se encarga de
conmutar la corriente desde las
escobillas hasta la bobina de campo y la
bobina de campo está hecha del núcleo
sólido y dentro hay un núcleo de hierro
blando el núcleo de hierro blando hacia
el campo magnético más potente y más
efectivo que si el núcleo fuera hueco
funciona igual que una bobina de alambre
de cobre enredado en un clavo crea un
campo electromagnético cuando la
corriente entra fluye por el enrollado
de cobre en la bobina y así es cómo
crear el campo electromagnético al
entrar la corriente por la bobina se
energiza creando un imán
electromagnético que empuja contra el
imán dentro de la cubierta
hay un imán que es el polo sur y hay
otro imán que es el polo norte y al
entrar en corriente eléctrica y empujar
contra el imán hace que gire y mientras
gira el campo se invierte empujando
contra el imán del polo sur y mientras
gira otra vez el campo se vuelve a
invertir y empuja contra el imán del
polo norte y eso hace que el motor gire
ahora la razón por la que suceden esos
cambios es por algo conocido como la
regla de la mano derecha
entonces punto mano derecha así hace
donde apunto tu pulgar es la dirección
en la que fluye la corriente eléctrica y
los demás dedos apuntan en la dirección
del campo entonces cuando la corriente
entra el campo se mueve en una dirección
cuando la corriente sale el campo se
mueve en otra dirección y por eso
necesita es un polo norte y polo sur
para mantener el motor girando y bueno
ahí lo tienes así es como funciona el
motor del robot ahora para invertir la
dirección de giro del motor lo que
tienes que hacer es cambiar el orden de
las conexiones positivo y negativo es
decir tomas el lado positivo de la
batería y lo conectas aquí
tomas el lado negativo de la batería y
lo conectas del otro
y eso hará que el motor gire hacia atrás
es decir inviertes el orden de las
conexiones pero eso lo veremos con
detalle en futuros vídeos